okay guys gremlins - I'm telling you
this movie should write itself first one
was a classic this should be pretty
straightforward basically all we're
doing is maintaining the integrity of
the original picture we want to do all
the stuff with the water and the can we
help you I'm sorry let me introduce
myself
hi y'all my name is Starr magic Jackson
jr. I'm the Hollywood sequel doctor so
studio just brings me in to oversee
things when they about to drop a deuce
so that's why I'm here but don't mind me
I'm just gonna be over here y'all do
your thing it's your movie okay
let's brainstorm Adam I'm just gonna
take place in an office building I was
thinking what if gizmo gets too wet from
the water cooler this time okay hold on
a second I'm sorry I'm going to step in
here just one second sweetheart
so what's wrong with y'all y'all lookin
like a bunch of sad sacks this is G two
people we writing gremlins to it should
be a party with pizza and anchovies
pineapple just come on lift up the
spirits look okay I'm gonna put a little
bit of spice into the mixture here what
if we did this everybody here gets to
design their own gremlin I don't see
that the gremlin design is broken it's
called brainstorming not brain drizzling
sweet pea okay shut your mouth for a
second look here's the thing none of
this is final so you mean like what if
there was like a brainy gremlin a brainy
gremlin
you talking about a gremlin with glasses
who could talk and sing New York New
York
that's brilliant it's in the movie done
well you said that nothing was final
that was before I heard the words brainy
and gremlin in the same sentence
together it's done I love it it's in the
movie
what about a spider gremlin gremlin with
eight legs and the whole racks just
catching pretty ladies in a web in an
office building oh my god it's in the
movie I love that next what about a bat
dribbler you mean a gremlin with
leathery wings just flying around
flip-flopping bust through a wall make a
perfect bat symbol in the wall get
outside getting some wet concrete jump
up on a building they're just dry in
place like a gargoyle when we are
cooking with gas now I love it it's in
the movie next could there be a female
gremlin lipstick boobies [ __ ] you have
here and little gremlin vajayjay I love
it so much that it's not only in the
movie but it's definitely in the movie
there's no backsies on now or nope
anytime soon yes
yes that's in the movie dawn that's why
we need a woman in the writers room next
I don't know but you do know because you
talk about adrenaline whose sole purpose
in this film it's just that you look
stupid ass [ __ ] yes it can be in the
movie and it ends in the movie done next
what about you silver fine of
electricity gremlin
you said noun and gremlin like you play
a bad name you just like a child you
have the brain of a child you do not
have a high IQ but you haphazardly came
up with a gremlin this is made out of
bolts that is zigzagging all over the
room and is done completely in animation
you a crazy person and your ideas and
the movies done next can we put the
Hulkster in what you talking about
putting Hulk Hogan professional wrestler
turned actor turned cultural icon in the
movie where he break the fourth wall of
the movie he's in by talking to the
audience you sir raging psychopath
that's it I don't even care anymore we
got the Hulkster in this [ __ ] so it's
done I don't have any more time so let
me just recap right now is brainy
gremlin spider gremlin back gremlin lady
gremlin googly-eyed gremlin electricity
gremlin Hulk Hogan's don't be in the
picture how about throwing a lemon
myself vegetable gremlin just write it
up I'm having so much fun thank you it's
all gonna be in the actual film now I
gotta go put some cowboys and back to
the Future 3 sayonara Yahoo
[Music]
okay you guys know that none of that is
gonna be in the actual movie
[Music]
you
you